AER I DON’T.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
FROM ONE SOCIAL MEDIA TO
ANOTHER.
FLORIDA CONGRESSWOMAN KAT
CAMMACK SENDING A SCATHING
LETTER TO FACEBOOK AFTER
REPORTEDLY FINDING ADS FOR HUMAN
SMUGGLERS AND CARTELS ON THE
PLATFORM SHE WROTE, IN PART.
FACEBOOK’S ROLE IN THE CRISIS AT
THE BORDER IS URGENT AND MUST BE
ADDRESSED IMMEDIATELY.
AS PEOPLE VISITED THESE PAGES,
MYSELF INCLUDED, FACEBOOK THEN
PROVIDED ADDITIONAL PAGES AND
POSTS OF RELATED ILLEGAL CONTENT
CONGRESSWOMAN CAMMACK IS A
MEMBER OF THE HOMELAND SECURITY
COMMITTEE AND SHE JOINS US NOW.
>> HI, STEVE, HOW ARE YOU DOING?
STEVE: DID YOU GO DOWN TO THE
SOUTHERN BORDER YOU SEE WITH
YOUR OWN TWO EYES AND TALKED TO
THE MIGRANTS ABOUT HOW THEY
HEARD ABOUT COMING THERE AND YOU
HEARD ALL ABOUT FACEBOOK.
THE CARTELS ARE BUYING ADS ON
FACEBOOK.
>> IT’S WILD.
IT IS ABSOLUTELY UNCONSCIONABLE
TO THINK THAT IT IS HAPPENING.
BUT I HAVE GOT TO TELL YOU MY
VERY FIRST BORDER TRIP WE HAD
JUST GOTTEN TO THE DONNA
PROCESSING FACILITY AND THERE
WAS A BUS LOAD OF VERY YOUNG
PARENTS AND CHILDREN UNDER THE
AGE OF 6.
I SPOKE TO 15-YEAR-OLD GIRL.
I SAID WHERE ARE YOU FROM?
SHE SAID GUATEMALA.
I SAID HOW DID YOU KNOW TO COME
HERE SHE SAID FACEBOOK.
I HADN’T BEEN FIVE MINUTES IN
THE DONNA PROCESSING FACILITY
WHEN I HEARD THE TERM FACEBOOK.
AND AS I WENT THROUGH THE
FACILITY, I KEPT HEARING FROM
KIDS, FROM ADULTS, FACEBOOK,
YES.
WE COORDINATED LOGISTICS THROUGH
FACEBOOK.
WE PAID THROUGH FACEBOOK.
WE TALKED ON WHAT’S APP. WHICH
IS OWNED BY FACEBOOK.
IT WAS A DISTURBING TREND.
WHEN I STARTED TALKING WITH HHI
AND SOME OF THE BORDER PATROL
AGENTS THEY HAVE SEEN THIS
FIRSTHAND.
I FIGURED HEY, I’M A MILLENNIAL,
I’M PRETTY SAVVY WITH FACEBOOK.
I WILL DO A QUICK SEARCH.
JUST THIS MORNING, YOU KNOW, AT
6:00 AS I’M SITTING DOWN TO DO
THIS INTERVIEW WITH YOU GUYS, I
PULL UP CONBRA.
VENDEE, LAZAR WITH SIX 6 GRAND A
SIMPLE SEARCH TO GET THE DATA.
THAT’S ALL IT TAKES TO FIND OUT
EXACTLY WHO TO PAY, HOW TO GET
HERE AND HOW YOU WILL GET
SMUGGLED ACROSS.
THEY EVEN TALK ABOUT IN THESE
ADS HOW YOU CAN TAKE A
6-YEAR-OLD OR UNDER OR IF YOU
ARE A SINGLE ADULT WHAT THEY
DUAL TO HELP GET YOU ACROSS.
IT’S ABSOLUTELY NUTS.
STEVE: IT IS NUTS.
AND THEY KNOW THAT IF YOU HAVE
GOT A KID, THEY WILL LET THE KID
IN AND THEY MIGHT LET YOU IN AS
WELL.
BUT, HERE’S THE THING.
AND YOU HAVE WRITTEN A LETTER TO
FACEBOOK AND YOU HAVE WRITTEN A
LETTER TOE MARK ZUCKERBERG TO
SAY HEY, LOOK WHAT YOU ARE
DOING.
BUT, THINK ABOUT IT.
THIS MEANS THAT FACEBOOK IS
MAKING MONEY FROM CARTELS AND
FROM HUMAN SMUGGLERS HOW CAN
THEY DO THAT?
>> IT’S ABSOLUTELY -- I MEAN,
$27 BILLION IS WHAT FACEBOOK
MADE IN THE FIRST QUARTER OF
THIS YEAR.
NOW, I’M NOT SAYING THAT THAT’S
ALL CARTEL MONEY, BUT THEY ARE
ADVERTISING ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
IF YOU LOOK IN MY HOME DISTRICT.
I HAVE A LITTLE MOM AND POP SHOP
THEY SELL HOMEMADE GELLIES, AND
THEY WERE BANNED FROM SELLING
ADVERTISEMENTS ON FACEBOOK.
BECAUSE OF THEY HAD BEEN FLAGGED
FOR CONSERVATIVE CONTENT.
I HAVE A SINGLE MOM IN OCALA WHO
OWNS A VIDEO PRODUCTION COMPANY.
AND SHE HAS BEEN BANNED FROM
SELLING ADS ON FACEBOOK.
BECAUSE SHE POSTED A PICTURE OF
HERSELF IN A MAGA HAT.
THIS IS UNCONSCIONABLE.
SO MY QUESTION TO MARK
ZUCKERBERG AND THE FOLKS AT
FACEBOOK, INSTEAD OF TARGETING
CONSERVATIVES, MAYBE WE SHOULD
FOCUS ON THE CARTELS INSTEAD.
RIGHT?
STEVE: YEAH, NO KIDDING.
WELL, LET’S SEE WHAT THEY DO.
I KNOW THAT AFTER YOU WROTE YOUR
LETTER, IT WAS A BIG STORY, AND,
YET, YOU JUST DID A SEARCH 37
MINUTES AGO AND THE ADS ARE
STILL THERE CONGRESSWOMAN,
BEFORE YOU GO, WE WERE TALKING A
MOMENT AGO ABOUT EARMARKS.
SO, ARE YOU ONE OF THE
REPUBLICAN CONGRESS PEOPLE WHO
HAVE SIGNED UP FOR MORE
GOVERNMENT CASH FOR YOUR
DISTRICT?
>> NO.
I CAN SAY THAT I AM PROUD TO
HAVE VOTED AGAINST EARMARKS AND
STOOD FIRM AGAINST THEM.
WASHINGTON HAS A SPENDING
PROBLEM.
NOT A SAVING PROBLEM.
SO, I THINK I CAN BETTER SERVE
MY CONSTITUENTS BY WORKING TO
RECOVER MONEY THAT’S ALREADY
OWED TO THEM THROUGH FEDERAL
AGENCIES RATHER THAN SPENDING
MORE OF THEIR HARD EARNED TAX
DOLLARS.
STEVE: THREW GO, ALL RIGHT.
CONGRESSWOMAN KAT CAMMACK
JOINING US FROM GAINESVILLE.
>> GOOD JOB.
STEVE: THERE WAS SOME CONCERN
WHETHER OR NOT I WOULD PRONOUNCE
HER NAME CORRECTLY AND I THINK I